Gershund therapy recommends a no salt diet is this how we should be eating. I don't think so. So remember, and I write about this in my book as well.
So some of the things that are in the the Gershund therapy that are going way back from the 1930s and 40s when Max Gershund wrote his book. So if you read Max versions book, you'll read things about absolutely nobody should be taking salt. Everybody should be on potassium.
Things like that that were a part of his original program was Charlotte.
Gershund has not changed anything from Max Gershund's original program. Some doctors that worked with her for a number of years. I know a German doctor that worked with her for a number of years and just trying to get her to go.
Let's come into the 21st century here. There's more data. There's more research. She just absolutely refused. She stays true to his program. And there's good things and bad things about them.
But I do think there's benefit to looking at new research and new data that can both prove that the efficacy of some of the things that you've done, but it can also disgroup some of the things that you've done. And we as practitioners need to stay humble in that new data comes out and we got to go, wow, this is really interesting. I need to start testing for this or start applying this.
Or boy, what I was doing now, I don't think was really correct. And we need to be humble enough to change that that goes for all of us.
So as far as a dose of diet, I don't think so. Now I will say with salt, there are some people. There's a percentage of the population that is so sensitive.
That has been proven with research around autoimmune disease and research around blood pressure and coronary heart disease. Some people that are sodium sensitive.
Well, sodium chloride will attach to receptors in the smooth muscle underneath the epithelial and cause contraction and increased blood pressure.
And the studies that I saw about over two thirds of the people are not sodium sensitive that it causes engagement with that receptor and sodium doesn't increase blood pressure.
But when some of that initial research came out, that's when they started saying back in the 70s and 80s and all high blood pressure people should live in their sodium. That's only true in a percentage of population of coronary patients that are sodium sensitive.
There's also a sodium sensitivity and sodium combined to receptors on immune cells and cause immune people with autoimmune disease to worsen, especially with poshimotos.
I write about that information and I think I've actually created video on it by the clinic disease and all of you in course in the last module, what I talked more specifically on poshimotos in autoimmune thyroid.
That is relatively new information and people with poshimotos, many of them that have that sodium sensitivity for their thyroid gland do much better at taking a high dose potassium before their meals.
Many people have just called out their triggers immensely. It's more information on the module six, I think it is on the autoimmune cause.
But I don't think, I don't think for most people with cancer that they have to be on a no-salt diet.